[Music]
one more thing Ben I noticed you go to
Ithaca College just so happens we have a
number of interns this semester from
Ithaca College this is totally true I
asked them to come out here there they
are they're all from Ithaca guys I
believe you have Ben's internship
application there yep right here Conan
it's not looking good for Africa
[Applause]
I hope we were rolling on that ah
they're still there yeah robots why we
all have so many how could there be so
many from one college who's running this
thing did you think was weird that you
all got in from Ithaca yeah
there's 12 yeah out of 40 how would that
happen Jeff
no one knows he was in charge of interns
he's in charge did you show up I thought
you're none of you are in trouble don't
worry okay yeah yeah I haven't decided
which two yet la program we live in the
Oakwood apartments then we get
internships you live in the oak I used
to live in the Oakwood apartments really
yeah yes I look at these okay yeah of
when I first came to LA in 85 that's
right
1885 I my writing partner nice lives in
those oak woods yeah it's a great place
to meet a divorced pregnant 35 year old
woman yeah I lived in that Oakwood and
then I lived in a different Oakwood for
a while I just wandered around from
Oakwood to Oakwood the girl that ran the
Oakwood that you're at she's you know
long dead now but but when I was looking
at that oak wood this very attractive
like very tall she looked like a young
Brooke Shields she was running the
Oakwood she was the manager and she was
a real fresh
she was real flirty with me and then she
said well if you played here you and I
could shoot baskets so my brain partner
night we sign up and like an idiot the
next day I show up with my basketball
I'm like hey so I thought maybe we could
shoot baskets and she's like you know
get out of here I got your signature you
SAP that's when I learned what this
town's all about
sorry I've been spouting off for a while
now I feel like Clint Eastwood talking
to an empty chair okay let's hear it to
the Ithaca gang come on
[Applause]
[Music]